Merry Christmas Ally try not to kill
anyone I was a newly qualified Junior
doctor and 3 weeks previously I'd made a
rookie error forgetting to fill out a
form to request the holidays off now
here I was managing a hospital Ward on
my own on Christmas Day things had
started badly and rapidly got worse
Medical School hadn't prepared me for
anything like this at the end of my
hardest day yet I felt completely
underwater and then from nowhere I
remembered some words of wisdom from my
old tutor Dr Barkley if the treatment
isn't working question the diagnosis
that night I hung up my stethoscope
grabbed a mince pie and opened my laptop
I'd once been so productive I thought
what had I forgotten it would take me a
few months but I was stumbling my way to
a revelation that everything I'd been
told about success was wrong I couldn't
hustle my way to becoming a good doctor
working harder wasn't going to bring me
happiness but for the first time I could
make out the beginnings of an
alternative approach an approach that
didn't hinge on exhaustingly hard work
but on understanding what made hard work
feel better an approach I would come to
refer to as Feelgood productivity
feel-good productivity is a simple
method but it changes everything it
shows that if you've ever felt
underwater you don't have to settle for
staying afloat you can learn how to
swing